oui c'est une élection qui m'intéresse
et oui je vais voter et parce que je
vote systématiquement j'estime que c'est
un devoir mais qu'il est important que
ce soit pour la région que ce soit pour
la ville de pouvoir voter
et ensuite avoir indirectement une part
pour les décisions qui sont prises à la
fois sur notre ville ou sur notre région
oui ça intéresse je suis ça un peu noir
envers mais je m'intéresse quand même
mais je pense pas que je vais aller
voter parce que je vais pas rester
française donc je vais pas voter
voilà je pense aller voter parce que
c'est nécessaire mais ça m'intéresse pas
non plus des masques
ça me je me sens pas vraiment concerné
ce soit dans que dans dans party ou de
l'autre des sélections régionales
parti de la vie lyonnaise de la région
nous avons
et surtout faire barrage à ces écolos
là c'est tout ça
c'est pour ça que j'irai voter le
scrutin des régionales m'intéresse
beaucoup moins que les scrutins
nationaux et législatives et puis les
présidentielles
oui mais j'irai quand même voter oui
pour essayer de faire un peu évoluer les
choses peuvent changer
bien sûr et je vais voter pour des gens
qui vont nous défendre parce que l'ama
ras-le-bol de cette clique
et voilà la marre de la misère en a
marre des gens qui crèvent et des autres
qui s'enrichissent de plus en plus donc
ce soit les socialistes la droite
en marche tout ce que vous voulez tant
l'instant il n'y a qu'un qui correspond
et qui dit ce qu'il pense
c'est mêlant chant même si je ne partage
pas forcément toutes ces idées mais au
moins j'ai contient non je pense que je
vais pas voter aux élections régionales
que c'est pas quelque chose qui
m'intéresse spécialement c'est pas
quelque chose je me sens ciblé dessus ah
oui pas parce que c'est le seul pouvoir
qu'on a dans le seul pouvoir cour n'a
donc cessé l'urne c'est c'est là qu'on
peut dire ce qu'on pense et après on n'a
personne
c'est ça mon idée
parce que j'ai horreur de gens qui se
plaignent mais qui vont pas voter john
paul arrivée qui apprécions pourquoi
voilà bah oui quand même un minimum
c'est la politique en bts intéressé à ça
c'est pas rien donc je pense faudrait
plus qu'un tiers et c'est un minimum
tout m'intéresse franchement c'est
passionnant je sais pas qui c'est qui va
se présenter je pense que l'actuel
président de la région se représenter je
pense que le hockey il ya je croyais à
et à madame belkacem je crois qui est
sûre les nice après je sais pas qui
c'est qui va se présenter mais je
connais pas trop les candidats